okay I've loaded a timeline trace I've
saved from an earlier session wait wait
you can save timeline traces oh yeah
it's a pretty awesome feature you can
just right-click on the timeline and
save any trace similarly you can load a
trace from a previous session in the
same way this is a really useful feature
whenever you're debugging a site and
wants to keep it for further analysis or
if you need to share it with someone Wow
all right I've been taking screenshots
really wish I had known about this
earlier yeah traces are definitely
better than screenshots I've put a link
to the trace we're looking at here in
the instructor notes why don't you
download it and open it on your machine
to follow along I'll wait a few seconds
okay let's look for some CSS events in
this trace first you can see the CSS
requests going out note that it happens
after the first chunk of HTML is
received this is where the parser finds
the link tag and initiates the CSS
request then we wait to get the CSS
bytes and finally a bit later we see the
recalculate style event which is where
we convert the CSS response into the CSS
object model in this particular case the
CSS is tiny so it only takes a few
milliseconds to do the conversion but
for larger style sheets this could
definitely take much longer okay so
before I rewrite all of my CSS rules
I should probably record the timeline
and check out how long this step is
taking right that's right measure first
then optimizes need it